buonasera
video giocavo teso nel cielo
e il mobile
se vi salgo portando pensieri e
preoccupazioni per il vento per il
troppo vuoto che c'è intorno
[Musica]
il cavo inizia a muoversi oscilla sotto
i miei piedi diventa un cavo difficile
vorrei correre via vorrei affrettarmi
una corsa un movimento brusco però
potrebbero essere fatali
[Musica]
rallento i miei passi
il mio respiro e cerco di attraversare
la difficoltà lentamente
ok io non sapevo che sarei finito su
quei cavi non sapevo cosa avrei fatto da
grande sapevo però bene cosa non volevo
fare e sapevo che le strade che mi
venivano proposti non mi bastavano erano
strade di alzate troppo presto al
mattino erano strade di sacrifici erano
strada in qualche modo di di rinuncia e
quindi mi sono messo un pochino a a
cercare una strada oltre le possibilità
che avevo al tempo in nel mio orizzonte
e ho trovato un buco una porta dove
passare durante uno spettacolo di strada
che vidi alla fiera degli oh bej oh bej
a milano ricordo ancora che vi di
rodrigo morganti ragazzi un performer
con cui poi lavorare negli anni
successivi anche durante alcuni festival
no e che aveva fatto cerchio e aveva
fatto spettacolo in strada liberamente
offrendo quello che la sua arte quella
che la sua volontà
voleva dare al pubblico in quel momento
e ricevendo liberamente quello che il
pubblico voleva dare affida alla fine
dello spettacolo
e così iniziai a fare a praticare la
giocoleria a fare teatro di strada fare
spettacoli a cappello in giro per per
l'italia tra le varie discipline o qui
mi dedicai oltre la giocoleria
c'era naturalmente l'equilibrismo e
nell'equilibrio mi dedicai un pochettino
al cavo al tempo diciamo tecnicamente
era un film ferrista cioè facevo il cavo
più o meno alto due metri lungo sei
metri sempre quelle di misure sembra
quelle distanze e continuavo a non avere
idea che si poteva fare una cosa di
questo genere
finché un giorno un organizzatore di un
festival mi dice guarda io il prossimo
anno vorrei fare per i dieci anni del
festival la traversata del canale che
c'è nella mia città
tu fai anche grandi altezze gli ho detto
non ancora ci siamo presi un anno per
organizzare questo evento e mi sono
dedicato iniziato a camminare su cavi un
pochino più alti un pochino più lunghi
poi quell evento non si è fatto perché
per qualche motivo un po che non ho
ancora capito comunque l'organizzatore a
un certo punto ha rinunciato a questo
evento io però ne stavo già parlando e
un altro organizzatore mi ha detto ma se
fai anche grandi altezze anch'io ho il
decennale del festival vorrei fare una
traversata
e così nel 2006 ho fatto la mia prima
grande traversata era attraversato il po
vicino a chivasso 120 metri di cavo a 12
metri di altezza
ho iniziato col botto beh a parte il
fatto che sono stati
si viaggia
a parte il fatto che ricordo benissimo
la settimana prima e la settimana dopo
in cui sono stato in botta tutto il
tempo all'idea di quella che sarebbe
stato e di quello che era stato però
quello che che ricordo con precisione e
quel primo passo sul cavo e la paura che
ho avuto a fare quel primo passo è la
ricordo bene non perché fosse una
particolare una paura particolare o in
particolarmente intenso speciale la
ricordo bene perché da 13 anni continua
a riviverla
ogni volta che faccio un primo passo su
un qualsiasi cavo di quelli che ho
camminato finora quella paura è rimasta
uguale per 13 anni
quello che è cambiato in questi anni è
il fatto che io quella paura piano piano
mi sono abituato
mi sono permesso di viverla e nonostante
la paura ho fatto e rifatto il primo
posto sul capo
ho imparato così per esempio come lavora
questa paura e ho visto che la paura non
lavora tanto su quello che sta davanti a
me perché fondamentalmente il vuoto è
una cosa ignota non ha una forma chiara
e quindi non è un oggetto chiaro che può
far paura la paura lavora su quello che
devo lasciare dietro per camminare sul
cavo perché non posso portare con me
pensieri non posso portare con me
preoccupazioni ricordi o aspettative
sono tutte cose troppo pesanti sono cose
che appartengono al passato al futuro
mentre sul cavo c'è un unico tempo e del
tempo presente
e quando si vive completamente il
presente si dimentica quello che c'è
dietro si dimentica quello che c'è
davanti è questo
dimenticare questo lasciare indietro fa
un pochettino paura perché lasciamo
indietro qualcosa che conosciamo bene
indipendentemente dal valore che questa
cosa ah però è conosciuta per qualcosa
che invece sta davanti a noi che non ne
conosciuto la paura lavora
sull'attaccamento che noi abbiamo a ciò
che conosciamo e ciò che abbiamo fatto
lavora sul fatto che crediamo che tutte
queste cose complesse comprese
preoccupazioni aspettative siano la
parte più importante di noi sono invece
le zavorre che io devo lasciare indietro
se voglio camminare sul cavo e per per
fronteggiare questo momento questo primo
passo è la paura che c'è in quel in
quell'attimo un momento prima di
sospendermi ho sviluppato un piccolo un
piccolo gesto che è diventato un piccolo
rito che io faccio ogni volta che devo
salire sul cavo è che questa sera però
vorrei condividere con voi
quindi vi invito a sedervi comodamente
ogni volta che invitò qualcuno una
platea sedersi comodamente vedo del
movimento no qualcuno che si stessi
sistema allora la mia domanda è perché
eravate scomodi fino a un attimo fax
comunque adesso che siamo seduti comodi
per favore mettiamo le mani sulle sulle
ginocchia sulle cosce con i palmi verso
l'alto chiudiamo gli occhi e lasciamo
che il nostro corpo respiri da solo
senza interferenze della nostra mente il
nostro corpo sa respirare benissimo
lasciamolo fare e portiamo
la nostra attenzione alla mano destra
se siete destri o quella sinistra se
siete mancini
quindi il prossimo respiro per favore
chiudete la mano a pugno mentre ispirate
e durante l'espirazione lasciate uscire
l'aria e lasciate che la mano si apra
che è diverso da volerlo aprire o farla
aprire si tratta proprio solo di
distendere abbandonare i muscoli che
prima abbiamo contratto quindi inspiro
chiudo la mano e spiro lascio che la
mano si apra
col prossimo respiro chiudiamo alla mano
con un pochino più di forza con un
pochino più di intensità e allo stesso
tempo quando abbiamo i polmoni pieni e
la mano chiusa
facciamo un piccolo controllo per vedere
di stare utilizzando solo i muscoli
necessari a questo gesto
controlliamo di non stare ingaggiando i
muscoli della spalla le sopracciglia gli
addominali le gambe insomma usiamo solo
il muscolo che ci serve per chiudere la
mano inspiro chiudono a mano piccolo
controllo di economia muscolare lascio
che la riesca lascio che la mano si apre
lavora con il prossimo respiro quando
abbiamo la mano chiuse e polmoni pieni
facciamo una piccola pausa una piccola
trattenuta a polmoni pieni
prima di lasciare uscire l'area è di
aprire la mano quindi spiro cento la
mano a polmoni pieni qua la mano chiusa
mi fermo un attimo lì e poi lascia
uscire l'aria lascio che la mano si apra
immaginiamo di rallentare la fase di
ispirazione e quindi di allungarla un po
e infine mettiamo anche un piccolo
attimo di attesa una piccola apnea
polmoni vuoti
quando la mano aperta quando è uscita
tutta l'area ci fermiamo
laggiù in fondo un secondo in più prima
di fare rientrare l'area quindi ispiro
chiudo la mano a polmoni pieni a mano
chiusa mi fermo un attimo piccola apnea
polmoni pieni lascia uscire l'aria
lascio che la mano si apra e laggiù in
fondo a polmoni vuoti mi fermo un attimo
in più prima di farli entrare l'aria
fate ancora per favore 3 respiri in
questo modo ognuno col proprio ritmo
dopo di che potete aprire gli occhi e
continuiamo
ok se c'è ancora qualcuno con gli occhi
chiusi
a questo punto io lo considero
addormentato e vado avanti
quindi grazie di aver fatto da grazie di
esservi prestati per questo breve
esercizio che ha per me due sensi 1
chiaramente di fisico mi aiuta ad avere
un corpo morbido e rilassato mi aiuta
nonostante la paura ad avere un respiro
profondo respiro che mi permette di
ossigenare bene tutto il corpo e mi
permette di essere efficiente
proprio nel momento più critico quando
tendenzialmente il nostro modo di
reagire quello di contrarsi e accorciare
il respiro ossia toglierci delle
possibilità nonostante la paura
nonostante la criticità
anzi proprio quando c'è paura proprio
quando c'è criticità è lì che abbiamo
bisogno di tutto il nostro potenziale e
dall'altra parte questo esercizio anche
un senso un significato più simbolico
per cui una mano chiusa e una mano che
sta trattenendo qualcosa nel momento in
cui si apre lascia andare quello che
tratteneva e proprio perché ha lasciato
andare e in grado di accogliere quello
che sarà ed è perché una mano che si
apre lascia andare pensieri lascia
andare le sovrastrutture lascia andare
il nostro io
piccolo e mi permette di camminare sul
cavo perché io andrea loreni questo io
piccole relativo non potrebbe
attraversare quei cieli
mi affido a qualcosa di più grande ma
per affidarmi a qualcosa di più grande e
devo lasciare andare il mio io piccolino
è questa naturalmente questo lasciar
andare lì ho una sorta di piccola morte
assimilabile o comunque che secondo me
accadde in quel momento in cui i polmoni
sono completamente vuoti
proprio quel momento lì è definito la p
una piccola morte perché c'è un momento
di abbandono di rilassamento di
destrutturazione di quello che ci sembra
costituirci però proprio grazie a questa
piccola morta questo fatto che lasciamo
andare qualcosa c'è la possibilità
passando attraverso il vuoto di
rinascere di ritornare come qualcosa di
nuovo e trasformato questo aspetto che
ci spaventa che è terrificante
e però il dato della nostra esistenza
siamo in continua trasformazione siamo
continuamente diversi e usciti di qua
questa sera faremo diversi da come siamo
entrati e non perché ho parlato io e gli
altri speaker senza nulla togliere né a
me né gli altri speaker saremo diversi
semplicemente perché sono passate due
tre ore e qualche prosecco però il punto
è che questo aspetto che ci spaventa è
il dato della nostra esistenza
ed è anche però la nostra più grande
possibilità quella di liberarsi di tutte
le nostre sovrastrutture e lasciarci
fiorire per quello che siamo veramente è
il modo che abbiamo di lasciare uscire
il copione in è di inedito di cui ha
parlato andrea all'inizio del ted di
lasciare uscire il nostro essere
ed ecco che allora sul cavo oltre la
paura per fortuna c'è anche la libertà
la libertà appunto di essere esattamente
dove siamo ma anche esattamente è solo
perché è sufficiente quello che siamo
veramente grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]